fox news alert queen elizabeth ii has
died ending the longest royal rule in
great britain's history the 96 year old
monarch passing away peacefully this
afternoon surrounded by the royal family
who rushed to be by her bedside in
balmoral her country estate in the
scottish highlands crowds are gathering
outside buckingham palace all day to pay
their respects as an entire nation
mourns the loss of their beloved icon
queen elizabeth's son prince charles now
the king of england called the king
consort with the official title of king
charles iii charles calling his mother's
death a moment of great sadness for him
and the royal family
newly installed british prime minister
liz truss who had just met with the
queen two days ago addressing the nation
it is a day of great loss
but queen elizabeth ii leaves a great
legacy
today the crown passes
as it has done for more than a thousand
years
to our new monarch our new head of state
his majesty king charles iii we usher in
a new era in the magnificent history of
our great country
exactly as her majesty would have wished
by saying the words
god save the king
and
the news breaking this morning judge
around 8 o'clock what was a real tell
was that when her doctors issued a
statement saying we are concerned for
her health and the british have a way of
understating things so that was set off
everyone to know okay this could really
be it and unfortunately it was i like
what uh the prime minister said a great
legacy
it is she did have a great legacy i mean
she's the only queen that i've ever
known and and most of the people uh in
the last 70 years have known anyway and
you know as an american i always looked
at her as someone who was incredibly
strong but when you think about all the
years that she was a queen she had a
front row seat to history she she was
she was the queen when winston churchill
was prime minister i mean and during
world war ii she apparently was a driver
and a mechanic and part of the women's
auxiliary i mean she was a tough woman
who incredibly as america's tried to
balance women and work in the workplace
in the 60s and the 70s she was doing it
in the 50s she was a young woman a queen
of 24 a mother a wife running a country
and she did it all with such elegance
such calm such finesse she was so stoic
and then you think about her with people
like ronald reagan i mean riding horses
with ronald reagan margaret thatcher
maggie thatcher another tough woman just
as the queen was um she was to me the
essence of balance and she has gone
through so much in the last few years
and yet she remained stoic and kind and
apparently a very giving woman and she
is really a a someone that we can all
model ourselves after in terms of her
ability to deal with stress and be the
woman who can run a house and the
country
in fact when you mention margaret
thatcher it makes me remember that at
the time queen elizabeth ii and margaret
thatcher were the two most powerful
women right in the world and something
to be said now i guess for the passing
of the baton delis trust as that her
first official assignment is to take the
nation through this funeral process
absolutely i'm sure that was something
incredibly special for prime minister
trust to get that opportunity and you
can't help but think since it was just
48 hours later that the queen really
wanted to be there that it was important
for her to stand there with the next
prime minister and a female prime
minister and welcome her
into that role even though uh you know
her duties are largely ceremonial there
um in terms of what she does with the
prime minister um so i lived in london
for six years i was there for the royal
wedding when will and kate got married
which was you you just couldn't help but
get into it and that's the thing
whatever you think about monarchy and
you know we could have conversations
about you know the history of
colonialism and all of that
it's special and the place that these
royals hold um in the hearts of the
people in the uk and and across the
commonwealth is
not something to be trifled with and i
i absolutely love it and i love being a
part of it and having to
have on the opportunity to sit there
and kind of see all the bunting come out
and the excitement
to catch a glimpse of them and i know
that everyone is sharing all these
incredible stories from her life but i i
have to say
anytime that that video is circulated of
what she did on september 12th where she
had them play the star-spangled banner
after um september 11th here it's just
you can't help but cry at these kinds of
gestures breaking 600 years of tradition
to uphold the special relationship that
the u.s and the uk has um and she really
ushered in the monarchy into a more
modern era and i thought she did it so
seamlessly and from how she dressed to
how she treated people um the way she is
with her grandkids um certainly after
diana died and then with her great
grandchildren i just tons of respect her
dresser one time angela kelly was her
name who's written a book about the
queen and it was very interesting about
the planning of all the outfits yeah
just like jesse i know has thought all
day about his outfit and what he was
going to wear today i'm kidding the
girls have gone on long enough
well i don't have as deep of thoughts as
the girls but
i do know we have this special
relationship with the british
historically and many people are
watching they don't really care
as much as other americans or as other
people in the commonwealth but this is
why it's important
many people from great britain came to
the united states to colonize it then we
went to war with the crown
a lot of people don't like the monarchy
i understand that but
what she represented
it was more than just the monarchy
it was the british empire and at that
time it was the greatest empire in the
entire
world
it's it's ever seen
and eventually the united states came
and rescued the british from world war
ii from the germans and we told them to
get rid of all their colonies and those
colonies were given their freedom and
they've lost a lot of power but we still
have the special relationship with great
britain we share intelligence we share
trade uh we share culture we share our
language and so when a monarch dies like
this who's seen i mean how many
presidents since truman americans see
the relationship through the eyes of her
relationship with our presidents
because every president that comes into
office they go and they go to london and
they meet the queen and that if you ask
the presidents probably might be
one of the most special if not the most
special moments of their presidency
because she represents more than a prime
minister she just
we don't have people like this anymore
and it gives you the chills to think
about it because she rises above
politics republicans democrats you
admire this woman because
you know if there's a war uh controversy
social injustice she has this graceful
way of rising above it
and and just doing what's best for her
people and doing what's best for the
world and and that's something very
significant we don't have people like
that anymore and that's the reason
people should pay attention to this
because we're in a new era now whether
we like it or not the truth yeah there
is something about tradition that people
tend to like right i know you're a big
you live in england for a while
tradition very pro
tradition
i was
i i was struck when you said that
doctors were very concerned about her
health she's 96 yep yeah but they never
say that
she's 96 they were concerned about her
health every day jimmy carter 97. so
there you go but she clearly lived a
unique life i mean it's one thing to be
a queen but it's another thing to live
to be practically at 100 i mean think
about that combination that's like
winning the lottery not only were you
royalty but for a century you were
royalty i would be happy living to be a
hundred or be in the royalty but to get
both is incredible but think about it
what killed her have you thought about
that
was it old age or was it the fact that
they stopped her from drinking her
martinis
you know this is what i will never
understand what people get yes when
people get older right they did this
with my mother when people get older
they go like oh maybe it'll save you a
month you know she couldn't drink her
martinis anymore that doesn't make you
live longer it makes you think you're
living longer because it feels that way
and meanwhile she can't drink while
she's dealing with meghan markle
that would drive anybody to drink and
she can't drink so i think that that was
that that it would have been nicer if
they let her have her you know uh what
do you call it nightly tipple yes you
know that was terrible but she had a
really she had a uniquely charmed life
and uh and a challenging life at that
and i'm looking forward to uh this new
monarchy is it gonna be a woke monarchy
oh here we go
a lot of climate change is gonna happen
should we all have a martini on behalf
of i think we should yeah we should pour
one out for our homie
uh anybody else have final thoughts
judge you know the people who
you saw on tv today talking about her
personally one of the things i thought
was fascinating was that they said that
she had like a funny side a happy side
and she did that paddington bear skit
where she's having tea with a paddington
bear and then at one point i think she
jumped out of a helicopter when she was
like 75 or something uh and she did
something with daniel craig i think for
one for the olympics yeah for the
olympics i mean you know she wasn't
afraid to mix it up so all the stoicism
that we saw i mean she had and by the
way i mean she put the pedal to the
metal i hear she like drove like a bat
out of hell but that's the story with
the saudi crown prince that he was
visiting in the early 2000s and in saudi
women can't drive and he got into the
car and was shocked she got in the
driver's seat and starts whizzing around
balmoral and he's going through his
translator please ask her to slow down
slow down and she didn't slow down one
bit i think it would be it would be
interesting to learn more about in fact
if we ever get a chance to read some of
her diaries about the time during the
cold war and how margaret thatcher
ronald reagan the pope um
our ally is trying to figure out a way
to break communism and she was very much
against communism i i did have a chance
to meet her i found this picture today i
don't know if you guys saw it it was in
2008 and i was kind of nervous to meet
her and joe hagan that was the deputy
chief of staff he pushed me forward to
meet the queen so i had a chance to say
hi to her but they make you so nervous
what is the problem
there's a list a mile long of things
that you should just lunge
well uh i can't remember some people
were having chords no honestly it's very
complicated that way like you could hurt
you're not i will tell you she didn't
care about any of that she was just
gracious i was so nice to meet you she
asked me she knew about peter my husband
being from britain so we talked a little
bit about that and i mean it was it was
a 45 second conversation but i'll always
remember it but at the time president
bush had brought her one of those little
uh electric vehicle golf cart things to
drive around and it had the union jack
on it and so she was getting
obama's presence oh yeah that was a good
president all of his speeches on a cd
for hurdles no no no no no no no on an
ipod on an ipod
a democrat in this we were having a
moment we just said that was a great
gift i thought it was a great gift no
it's something that i would give to the
queen you know it's amazing how
conspicuously silent he has been since
she passed away yeah what does that tell
you i think that's an investigative
report for your show
i needed an idea for tonight which of
course is coming up at seven i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now